-Welcome back, everybody.
You know,
it can be hard to say goodbye,
but sometimes you have to,
and there are a few things
I'd like to say goodbye to
right now.
It's time for "Go On, Git.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Go on, go on, go on, git
-[ Southern accent ]
Go on, git, weatherman
telling me that 90-degree
weather's gonna "feel" like 101.
Well, here I am, a common fool
thinking that
because it's 90 degrees ou
it's gonna feel like 90 degrees.
But, no, apparently
it's gonna "feel"
11 degrees hotter that that.
I feel like I'm eating catfish
by the sun!
I'll tell you what, weatherman
"Feels" like you should go on,
git!
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git, streaming services
Hollywood Video used to have
everything
you'd ever wanna watch,
but now I'm supposed to remember
which one of y'all has "Ozark"
and which one of y'all has
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel"?
It shouldn't be so dang hard
to watch my "Maisel."
From now on, the only servic
I'll be subscribing to
is the one called git.
[ Wind howling ]
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git, the name Gregg
spelled with two Gs.
It's pronounced Greg.
Not Greg-g.
Now g-go on and g-git!
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git,
random Wi-Fi networks
that my phone keeps
trying to connect to.
N-Now, you listen here
and you listen good.
I have an honorable phone,
and it will not be hooking u
with just any old Wi-Fi networ
that happens to be open
for business, you hear?
And you're not exactly giving me
confidence with a name lik
"Free Wi-Fi Unlimited Now
Free Connect Now."
Besides, I got my own Wi-F
network. Her name is Bessy
Password "go on,"
but the second O is a zero
Git!
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git, sandwiches
with toothpicks in 'em.
I'm trying to eat you,
not trying to get
the roof of my mouth
to participate
in a tiny sword fight,
so git outta my BLT and G-I-T!
[ Wind howling ]
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git, Instagram Live
letting people know
that I'm watching them.
I just wanted
to check in quick to see
if my sister's ex-boyfrien
could deejay,
but now he knows I'm here
and I can't leave
because I'm the only one
watching.
Heck, I think he's playing
somethin' just for me.
Well, I have a request.
How 'bout "Git Me Outta Here
by the artist Go on, Git?
♪♪♪♪
Go on, git, moths.
I don't mean to sound rude
but you're dumb as hell.
All you do is eat clothes an
get hypnotized by light bulbs.
Plus you're all pale
and up all night
like some kind of
vampire butterfly.
So, make like "Twilight" and
after five movies, go on, git.
[ Wind howling ]
Well, it's hard to see 'em go,
but I'm glad
I got that outta my system
Stay tuned for Andy Samberg.
♪♪♪♪